hey guys Pete here this is going to be a
Westworld season 2 episode 3 recap not
exactly sure what to call it since I
can't do it til later in the week I'm
gonna dial back the scene-by-scene
breakdown because I'm gonna assume by
this time you've already watched one of
those if not several of those and I
suppose that I'll dig a little deeper
into theories and what people are
thinking about since I have that little
bit of time to look through all that
stuff before I make the video cepsa it
was called vert to be Fortuna which is
Italian from what I understand that this
is a Makaveli in concept and a really
simple explanation sort of comes down to
virtue is representative of things that
you have control over like not virtue in
the sense of morality but in the sense
of things that you do well you know that
it restraints unfortunate things you
can't control things that happen
regardless of preparation the unknown
luck if you will on first watch it was
not my favorite episode I do have to say
though that after I watched it again it
was much more satisfying and the third
time I watched it I got a lot more
interested in the story of what's going
on and all those questions that are
still fun to think about when it comes
to host versus humans so we start off
with a cold open for the second week in
a row we get this new park which is
called the ROG
there was a theory going around that
that's what one of the parks was and we
found out that was the case for sure I
read quite a bit about people saying
that this is crazy that they would have
a park like this I I don't think it's
that crazy though when you think about
the situation at least what I could say
is that I could see why they chose to do
something like this and why that would
appeal to a certain subset of people
anyways we meet a new character who were
gonna call grace that's what she's been
referred to on IMDB that could be
planted there there's some also some arg
stuff where a QA person named grace
exists
and I'm not gonna go completely down
that rabbit hole at this moment but when
I first watched it I didn't really care
much I was I liked it I liked this twist
we weren't expecting this we were
expecting Shogun world so I liked that
it was something to think about some new
I didn't know whether the characters
were gonna be recurring so I didn't know
if you know we were really supposed to
have any feelings about them whatsoever
by the end of it we realized that grace
probably is very important the popular
theory is is that she is the main
mBLAQ's a daughter there's no real great
evidence for this but the other popular
theory is that it's another trick on the
timeline you know trick us out like how
young William was last year and that
this is actually a young Teresa and I
don't really follow that at all I don't
think that's the case I've been wrong
before when it comes to Westworld
theories though so that's out there
I think the William one makes a little
more sense but I did read in an article
written by James Hibbert who has
probably seen the whole season already
he said that all he could say is that
she is important she will return as far
as the timeline I think that this is
during the robot uprising so it's back
in time a little bit but not like way
back to when Teresa was young so I think
we can leave it at that grace is an
important character we'll find out more
about her as things go on and the Raj is
a place and we can find out that host
went off-script in other parks as well
as in West world at least in this one
case where a human was killed there's a
transition scene here that is after Paul
strand enters the park when he first
enters the park we see Bernard there
with him and they run into Charlotte she
delivers a really conspicuous Oh Bernard
you made it out I didn't think you had
it in you kind of line and that set up
red flags to me each and every time I
watch this obviously there's something
going on let's put
there's a few good theories or at least
they're fleshed out well I don't know if
I subscribe to either as being confirmed
obviously not or else I would be saying
that it's been figured out but I think
this really kind of points out again
that there's something going on with
Barnard and that first scene where we
see him you know the scar we see it
sometimes we don't see it so there's
likely more than one Barnard and you
know we also saw that in the trailer
there's a shot of Charlotte with several
Bernards so they're not active or
whatever but still you know the theories
here are that when we see Bernard in the
beginning in the beginning of the season
at the beach
that's not Bernard in there at all I
think the most popular theory is that
it's Teddy inside Bernards body because
we see Teddy under the water and because
of the rickroll video and a couple other
things there's there's some pretty good
bits of information that could back this
up
the other part that sort of goes along
with this is is that everyone knows
Bernards a host and they're bringing him
back online like we see him in the
beginning where we think it's Arnold we
think that Arnold's talking to Dolores
in the past it could be the other way
around it could be Dolores talking to
Bernard after she brings him back online
and the other part of that is that they
need to find something out through
Bernard so they keep running him through
this loop where the beach sequence
happens those things could both turn out
to be true it could really be anybody
inside Bernards body if we're gonna get
the idea that they can switch the eggs
around inside their heads so I'm not
fully endorsing any of them yet but I
think it's cool to think about what
might be going on and they definitely
laid that out early on that he's an
unreliable narrator based on this brain
fluid that's leaking out of his you know
his host juice that's coming out of his
ear and it could basically be anybody so
that's cool I like that he could be
Arnold he could be just regular old
Bernard he could be super Bernard he
could be Teddy he could be Dolores for
that matter
there's lots of ways that could go they
might know he's a host they might not
know he's a host who knows I can't wait
to find out more about it but we do see
how Abernathy ends up getting away from
Charlotte the first time she mentions to
Menard that he keeps slipping away from
us so even though she ends up with him
at the end of this episode we know that
he slips away again
we get to see Bernard adjust rebus to
use him as a pawn to get Abernathy free
that was kind of cool and it called back
to the first episode of when we see
rebus jump in front of the woman who's
about to be shot but at the end of the
day Charlotte ditches Bernard if she
thinks he's human that's kind of cold
she's only looking out for herself but I
think we already knew that about this
character at the same time Bernard gets
caught and that takes him and Abernathy
over to Fort forgone hope now I have
been critical of Dolores --is seen so
far in that I just don't feel that
connected to what she's doing she's sort
of out for revenge and I didn't expect
that that would be how her story would
play out at this point on first watch I
was sort of like who cares whenever she
had her sad scene with Abernathy because
she's just been programmed that that's
his father she's that other father so on
and so forth I thought to myself why
does Craddock care that she sold out his
men when he she's already resurrected
men in front of him like they're not
dead not in the real sense of it anyways
but on second watch I I've found it a
lot more compelling in that she may have
been programmed to love this guy that
maybe you know where that comes from but
it doesn't invalidate that connection
and you know it makes me think about
human relationships and how you know you
can feel connected to someone but that
doesn't necessarily mean that it's real
so why couldn't the opposite be true
when we're talking about hosts and I
think this is further kind of fleshed
out whenever Sizemore is saying to Mae
Hector that they can't actually be in
love so I think there's some interesting
stuff going on here and I think that the
showrunners haven't lost their minds I
don't think they have anyways and they
haven't forgotten how to make a
compelling story but they are fully
aware of the hive mind and how it goes
after TV shows in this era like the
reddit stuff and everything else I mean
a big knock on the show last season was
that everybody figured out all the
twists before they were revealed and
even though I didn't think that took
away from it I have hope that it is
going to play out where all of this
makes sense
like I'm fully not into what's going on
with Dolores but I'm not ready to tuck
out the whole show because I think it
will all pay off I could be wrong but I
don't think I'm going to be and we're
just gonna have to wait and see but yeah
I wasn't a big fan of the Della's charge
on I mean it just seems like yeah I know
that we know that they're incompetent
the security forces and that the hosts
are somewhat superior in a lot of ways
but some of it just seems like
inexplicably bad planning and I don't
know if we're just were supposed to
suspend disbelief here and hey there was
an explosion I don't know why it wasn't
my favorite part but then again I've
talked to other people and they really
liked that there was some action and
some stuff blown up so I guess you know
to each his own the other big problem I
had here was that they didn't secure the
back at all like they just Charlotte and
her people could just walk in of course
they didn't all walk out but you know it
was a little bit surprising to me that
she was able to get a hold of Abernathy
so easily but before all that goes down
we do see Bernard poking around inside a
pronoun thiis brain he sees that there's
a really large encrypted file there and
he does see a one-time-use key which I
won't go into it I did research about
this and the reason I'm not gonna go
into it too deeply is because we didn't
see him activate anything so you know
there's theories that he actually did he
downloaded the info he's carrying the
around he knows what the key is that's
why they're running him through the loop
and so on and so forth but we don't
really know because Bernard is in a
diminished capacity we see this as he
tries to walk away later and he's
unreliable so we can't guarantee that
any of that stuff happened but it is
something to keep in the back of our
mind he may have access to information
or he may know what it is but you know
the whole idea of him putting it in his
head and that's why he's glitching out I
don't think that's the case the
network's down he had to port in he took
the pad out of Abernathy's arm when the
QA guys come in so unless he put it into
the pad and then plugged the pad into
himself and this big elaborate thing I
think that the information that they
want is still in Abernathy I was talking
about this with someone earlier today
and I think that the information is
actually probably what they've been
collecting not just intellectual
property on how the hosts work and
things like that last season that was
what I thought it was but now that we
know more that they have this little
underground bunker where they're
collecting all this information there's
more to what that data probably is than
just how to make a host f foregone hope
we also see Teddy go against the lorises
wishes she tells him to kill Craddock
after the battle he lets Craddock go of
course in the teaser for next episode we
see that that frees up Craddock to go
out and team up with the man in black
I'd like to think that it's not just a
situation where they're like well we
need to keep this character alive that
there's some higher purpose to what went
down between Teddy and Dolores they're
like she's testing him and even though
he didn't pass the test that it's not
exactly as straightforward as it all
looks because earlier in the episode she
says to him you're all I had left and
that would be kind of a short-lived
situation if he's all of a sudden
completely off her list of trusted
entities one of my favorite parts of the
entire episode did happen in this though
and that was zombie Clementine I don't
know what the you
the effect that they use how they do it
but when she's dragging people around
and the way she moves I really enjoy
that I don't know it's it hasn't gotten
old yet I've watched it three times now
and I still like watching her glide
around dragging people if she does knock
Bernard out and drag him away that is
where he ends up for the time being
Delores says that she's got to go to
Sweetwater with Teddy and everyone else
I guess would be out looking for a
brunette
so things end up with Maeve the ghost
nation approached her Hector and
Sizemore and this has really opened the
door to a lot of speculation about what
the ghost nation actually is how are
they different from the other hosts
Maeve here can't control him she doesn't
he doesn't do what she wants like other
hosts have done in the past that makes
them seem different
Hector seems unwilling to shoot them
which is strange but they are willing to
let them go if they'll give them Lea
Sizemore who is the only human that's
there so they end up in an elevator they
go underground they hook back up with
Armistice and Felix and Sylvester
Armistice has a great entrance Lee has a
little bit of a breakdown because he
doesn't get how it's possible that Maeve
and Hector could choose to be in love
with each other we find out that Hector
is actually an idealized version of Lee
himself which is interesting since
they're going off together and that lead
isn't very capable and Hector obviously
is but yeah I mean the whole ghost
nation zing is really kind of a big deal
at this point well it's a big deal
because the last time we saw Stubbs in
season 1 we thought he was being
attacked by the ghost nation but then in
season 2 we see him pop up like nothing
ever happened
we haven't been filled in on what
happened there which makes it mysterious
so we have the ghost nation who I
thought were an interesting thing
briefly in the first season when they
started talking about and this was in
a story as well about how there had a
sort of idea of who their gods were you
know the guys in the costumes underneath
and they sort of just brushed right over
that a lot of the theories that are
floating around now are based off of
well maybe Ford had set these guys up to
protect humans in the park there were
like an internal security layer that's
why they want Sizemore then there's
Elsie who hasn't shown up we know she's
coming back this season perhaps she was
taken and she reprogrammed them to be
that way and then there's just they
could just be something else entirely
they could have reached sentience on
their own or some level of it and
they've just made their own decisions
and developed in a different way I kind
of like that the best it's the most fun
to speculate about but Elsie is coming
back and we do need to find out what
happened to her what happened to Stubbs
that's a big question mark in the
timeline of the story and it may be
related to that it's a lot was made
about how we've never seen them hurt a
human when they find grace they seemed
to be there to receive her not to attack
her she is with them so we can only find
out there about and more about what
she's about but yeah I didn't think much
about the exchange between Sizemore and
Maeve the first time I watched it and
Hector until I watched again and I
thought more about Dolores and Abernathy
and I mean that is kind of the whole
thing with me right now is that she
knows intellectually that that post is
not her daughter but she doesn't care
from what we seen from Dolores Dolores
knows intellectually she knows
everything she remembers everything
that's ever happened to her and she
knows that Abernathy's not really her
father but she doesn't care so there's
some irrational 'ti around love or
around strong feelings of connection
that hosts have that's very similar to
what we develop ourselves as humans and
of course the episode ends up with a
cliffhanger which kind of sucks but I
think it's sort of like at this point
there's so many storylines that there's
just gonna have to be some of this kind
of stuff like we didn't get any man in
black here
the pacing is just the way it is you
know I mean you can't hit sort of like
Game of Thrones there's so many
characters doing so many things you
can't touch on all of them in one
episode so they're gonna spread out and
then as they come back together we'll be
able to tie all this stuff up in a nice
little bow before the end of the season
Sizemore doesn't really know where he's
going or where he's at I think is what
they're saying anyways they end up
getting charged by a samurai in Shogun
world we see that Delos can control the
weather at least somewhat and we also
saw this in the trailer with the rain in
Lawrence's little part of the world
there there's more here the grace
character I you know there's like I said
there's several different series her
notebook there we saw that double
hexagon we've seen that in other places
we've seen that on the screen whenever
Charlotte logs in to try to get a rescue
operation we saw that in this episode
again whenever Bernard is poking around
in Abernathy's brain to me I haven't
really heard a lot of people talk about
this yet but I to me that kind of ties
whatever Charlotte's doing together with
grace however it could be that grace is
just an employee and that she's doing
the same kind of stuff that Charlotte
was doing when she came to the park I
mean nobody knew who she was when she
first showed up the other side of that
is is that grace could be an industrial
spy and she's there to try to get a hold
of the data and therefore she'll be
after Abernathy as well but you know
it's too early to tell it's really too
early to tell exactly how that's gonna
fit in but it's a lot of stuff to think
about and that's alright as far as I'm
concerned I did do a trailer breakdown
for the next episode and we see that
it's gonna probably be around the men in
black him hooking up with major Craddock
and we'll see more a bernard and
charlotte in the underground bunker i'm
curious to hear what you guys think
about these series i mean obviously a
lot of them have gotten popular bernard
equals teddy is probably the most
excepted I think at this moment some
other interesting ones is that this
narrative that forward put together for
William is gonna actually end with him
coming across the younger version of
himself a host version of himself and
Ford basically offering him a chance to
do it again but yeah I don't know I mean
that seems cool I mean I'd like to see
more Jimmy Simpson and stuff like that
but you know one of the things that we
have to remember about Westworld and one
of the things that really comforts me
when I'm afraid that it might derail is
that this isn't a meandering story that
they're writing as they go along they
know where the end is of course it could
probably change and whatever but you
know they took time after they shot the
pilot to write out an outline of how all
the seasons will go and what the ending
of the story is so we shouldn't run into
one of those lost situations where you
know there's all this stuff that seems
important but it turns out not to be if
that's the case which I think it is then
all we have to really worry about is
that they can land the plane you know
what I mean they they got quality actors
they got HBO throwing a ton of money at
this and the story so far is compelling
to me so at the same time anything we
see in the season is part of a bigger
picture so you know it's hard to say
what that bigger picture is so I'd like
to hear what you guys think where do you
see things going from here I can't
commit to doing these every week this
week turned out pretty good I had some
extra time I'm gonna try to I wanted to
thank you guys for the comments on the
trailer breakdown and the encouragement
to do it I didn't get to respond to a
lot of it because I just haven't been on
there but it's you know it was nice to
hear that you guys wanted to see this
and it made it worthwhile so thanks for
that and please like this video please
subscribe to my channel and thanks for
watching I'll talk to you soon